phoenix runde guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen sabine müller ist bei
uns sie ist korrespondent im hörfunk für
das für den hessischen rundfunk hr ard
hauptstadtstudio und beobachtet
natürlich die spd und die wahlen ganz
intensiv oswald metzger publizist der
war erst mitglied der spd dann für die
grünen im bundestag und später
stellvertretender vorsitzender der cdu
mittelstandsvereinigung kennt also drei
parteien gut nico sigel hatte ein
arbeitsreiches wochenende in münchen
denn er ist geschäftsführer vom
wahlforschungsinstitut infratest dimap
und professor thorsten faas
politikwissenschaftler an der freien
universität berlin beschäftigt sich mit
wahlverhalten und der wirkung zwischen
medien und politik hervor
nach bayern schauen jetzt natürlich alle
auf hessen wir haben heute abend das
duell sehen können zwischen thorsten
schäfer gümbel von der spd und volker
bouffier dem ministerpräsidenten das
analysieren wir später auch noch mal ein
bisschen schauen wir aber nochmal kurz
auf bayern war das jetzt ein bayerisches
tief oder ist es einfach eine allgemeine
existenzbedrohende schwäche was die spd
da gerade erlebt er bei der ist aber sie
haben es eben schon gesagt diese
einstelligkeit die hat natürlich noch
mal eine symbolkraft entwickelt die dem
ganzen noch mal ganz neue dynamik
verliehen hat und man darf nicht nicht
vergessen der bayerische landesverband
der spd ist der zweitgrößte innerhalb
der spd bundesweit das heißt wenn man so
eine ganz seltsame situation dass dort
viele viele mitglieder sind die extrem
enttäuscht sind über dieses ergebnis und
gleichzeitig dass bayern im bundesrat
für die spd zumindest marginalisiert und
das schafft glaube ich noch mal
innerhalb der spd ist eine ganz eigene
dynamik was ist ja immer bayern war
schwierig für die spd bei wählerinnen
und wählern ja bei mitgliedern eben gar
nicht so sehr an das schafft eben diese
diese divergenz dass jetzt innerhalb der
partei da habe ich wirklich aufruhr
herrscht das eben auch viele mitglieder
aus bayern
diese aufruhr nach berlin tragen und
dass die wählerinnen und wähler aber in
bayern jetzt einfach ganz ganz anders
entschieden haben und die spd wenn man
ehrlich ist eigentlich dort kaum mehr
auf dem schirm aufruhr sagen sie an dem
wahlabend wenn man nach berlin geschaut
hat ins willy-brandt-haus da waren sie
frau müller hatte man das gefühl der ist
so eine schockstarre wie haben sie das
erlebt an dem wahlabend als das ergebnis
bekannt wurde
ja das war schon so zumal die spd auch
nicht ihre übliche wahlparty hatte die
eh schon ein bisschen geschrumpft war
bei den letzten landtagswahlen aber
diesmal ganz ausgefallen ist offiziell
aus geldgründen also das heißt da saßen
einfach ich glaube zu zwei dutzend
journalisten saßen rom im atrium unter
der willy brandt statue und irgendwann
als dann tatsächlich klar war wie ist es
ausgegangen kam der generalsekretär lars
klingbeil raus hat glaube ich noch mehr
geschwitzt als sonst ob dieses
einstelligen ergebnis irgendwann dann
auch parteichefin andrea nahles ich
glaube eine minute 20 hat sie geredet
weil es auch nicht mehr zu sagen gab ich
habe sie glaube ich selten so bleich
gesehen das war wirklich wie versteinert
was sie da vorgetragen hat und ich
glaube die hatten einfach keine
antworten das hat man auch in den
interviews dann gemerkt glaube ich diese
gegeben haben wie kam das dann
eigentlich dass sie da so alleine stand
sie hat ja auch noch stellvertretende
parteivorsitzende es gibt auch noch ein
vizekanzler wie wie kann das denn
ja das ist tatsächlich so viele hatten
auch erwartet einig dass vor allem olaf
scholz da war der war ja am tag vorher
aus indonesien aus bali ganz überstürzt
abgereist per linie weil sie ein
regierungsflieger kaputt war auch mit
der begründung ihr müsst jetzt ganz
schnell nach berlin wahlanalyse machen
ich glaube ein paar waren erstaunt dass
er nicht da war ralf stegner der
unermüdliche parteivize hat sich
wenigstens noch mit dahin gestellt
hinterher vor die kameras aber
offensichtlich hat sich sonst auch
niemand gefunden der 9,7 prozent mit
kommentieren wollte also schon eine
bittere niederlage für die spd
herr siegel sie realisieren dass
natürlich ganz genau schauen darauf wer
hat die spd verlassen in bayern das
waren ja sie haben ja das ergebnis fast
halbiert da ganz viele und in alle
richtungen am stärksten natürlich zu den
grünen und rund ein fünftel der
wählerinnen und wähler aus dem jahre
2013 gingen zu den grünen aber sie haben
in alle richtungen verloren
und was natürlich was symbolkraft angeht
die einstelligkeit dann auch noch das
schlechteste ergebnis überhaupt bei
einer landtagswahl in der bundesrepublik
nicht mal in dem ostdeutschen bundesland
könnte man fast sagen es ist aber noch
ein bisschen mehr
und was natürlich für die spd auch was
die zukunft angeht ganz bitte ist sie
konfrontieren sich mit dem doppelten
sterbeprozess ihn sterben wie der union
viele ältere wählerinnen und wähler weg
bei denen sie noch relativ hohen
rückhalt haben und es wachsen weniger
junge nach
die spd war ohne den erst und
jungwählern in bayern so schwach media
fd schwächer als die fdp schwächer als
die grünen ohnehin deutlich schwächeres
die csu und selbst schwächer als die
freien wähler und das ist natürlich als
symbolkraft ein großes negative zeichen
was die zukunftsfähigkeit dieser partei
angeht aber wenn man dann gehört hat am
wahlabend haben alle immer davon geredet
der rückenwind hat gefehlt und das ist
eigentlich ist vor allem auch schuld
dass es eben in berlin nicht läuft und
das ist mit der großen koalition nicht
läuft ist das ihr eindruck auch weil das
sie mit der großen koalition nicht gut
läuft und gerade die spd damit probleme
hat dass das auch so zu sagen jetzt die
quittung ist die man in bayern erhalten
hat also das war die spd aufklärung
selber also wenn ich als partner immer
ein verlust erklären nämlich sage der
streit bei der konkurrenz hat mir
geschadet
dein tipp ich nicht mehr richtig sagen
also deutlich die spd hat ihre ihren
inneren kompass verloren aus meiner
sicht und das ist ein prozess der nichts
mit den koalitions querelen dieses
sommers zu tun hat sondern der zeichnet
sich ja schon länger ab ich meine die
wahlniederlagen der spd haben inzwischen
schon eine etwas längere geschichte und
wenn sie sehen mit welchen mühen diese
partei in diese große koalition allein
das hick hack mit der
entscheidungsfindung also aus meiner
sicht wird spätestens die hessen wahl
wenn das ergebnis in der richtung läuft
die einen ähnlichen spd verlust vor sie
zu sagen wir mal von 8 9 prozent und bei
der cdu was übrigens damit sie mich dann
nicht falsch verstehen wird auch um 19
prozent runtergehen dann wird die frage
raus aus der koalition laufen und dann
werden wir in berlin ganz munterer
wochen nach dem 29 oktober erleben wie
sehen sie es formuliert was hören sie
hier auch in der stimmung in der
bundestagsfraktion ist das so die diese
stimmung das auf hessen kommt es jetzt
an und dann auch bei cdu und spd dann
geht es ums ganze
ich glaube schon dass das die stimmung
ist ich weiß noch nicht genau ob wir
tatsächlich dann auch direkt auf den
koalitionsbruch zu steuern wie das bei
ihnen herr metzger grad so ein bisschen
angeklungen ist weil man muss sich aber
überlegen die spd ist der uns gesagt
unter schmerzen in diese koalition
reingegangen immer mit seiner ganz
staatstragenden attitüde und hat gesagt
wir machen das nicht für uns für unsere
partei damit es uns besser geht damit
wir ein paar minister ämter abräumen
sondern wir machen das damit es den
bürgern besser
und sich jetzt vorzustellen dass diese
partei danach zwei landtagswahlen wo die
eine wie wir schon wissen sehr schlecht
ausgegangen ist bei anderen business
eben noch nicht aber dass die partei
dann als argument bringt diese große
koalition tut uns nicht gut und deswegen
gehen wir raus
ich glaube das kann sich die spd so
nicht leisten das höre ich auch wenn ich
mit spd-linken rede dass die sagen naja
wir bräuchten eigentlich schon einen
guten ausstiegs grund wenn wir das
machen wollen und das können nicht zwei
schlechte wahlergebnisse sein wenn es
denn so ausgeht sondern es muss
eigentlich ein inhaltliches thema sein
und am besten noch ein wirklich
sozialdemokratisches herzensthema wo wir
sagen können leute das hätten wir
gebraucht das brauchen wir für die
bürger damit es den besser geht und weil
wir das nicht kriegen gehen wir raus
also ich bin wirklich mal sehr gespannt
ja wenn sie am ende der spd fehlt der
innere kompass würden sie das auch so
sehen gibt es da nicht mehr
ja das eine feste thema wo man sagt das
ist dafür steht die sozialdemokratie
infratest dimap hatte für mich eine sehr
faszinierende zahl am sonntag erhoben
nämlich die inkompetenz zahl im bereich
soziale gerechtigkeit
30 prozent waren das noch und soziale
gerechtigkeit ist für die spd nicht
irgendein thema sondern das kernthema
der markenkern würde man heute sagen
wenn dieses thema dieser
kompetenzbereich verloren geht
naja dann ist die spd wirklich in
existenziellen nöten
ihr fehlt einfach das vertrauen oder man
vertraut ihnen nicht mehr
insofern geht es glaube ich auch gar
nicht rum jetzt bestimmte position
irgendwie nachzujustieren sondern es
geht wirklich darum was traut man dieser
partei eigentlich noch zu kann man ihr
vertrauen ist ja authentisch und ich
glaube dann sind wir eben doch bei der
großen koalition weil der eindruck den
die große koalition erwägt er führt dazu
dass die leute denken wir beschäftigen
mit sich selber aber glaubwürdigkeit aus
dieser zerstrittenen koalition raus
wieder zu gewinnen ist wirklich kaum
möglich und insofern erkennt die spd
glaube ich gerade dass diese strategie
wir machen gute arbeit damit überzeugen
wieder damit gewinne wieder vertrauen
dass diese strategie gerade wirklich
grandios zu scheitern droht aber warum
ist die spd nicht mehr so glaubwürdig
erschienen
der kombi faktoren dazu natürlich kämpft
sie nach wie vor auch parteiintern mit
internen spaltung mit den folgen der
agenda 2010
die spd hat zwei große
modernisierungsschritte in ihrer
geschichte der bundesrepublik 3 genauer
gemacht das erste mal dass bad
godesberger
programm zur eröffnung der sozialen
marktwirtschaft anfang der 70er jahre
die politik der inneren reformen und
neuen ostpolitik willy brandt und dann
eigentlich in einer großen strukturellen
arbeitsmarktkrise die agenda 2010
das hat die partei gerade was den
sozialdemokratischen markenkern angeht
ein stückweit intern gespalten
aber ich glaube man muss schon die
langfristigen strukturellen fragen
unterscheiden von kurzfristigen
strukturell ist es so dass csu cdu und
spd als große volksparteien seit den
1970 er jahren insgesamt rückläufigen
rückhalt in der bevölkerung haben dann
kommen kurzfristige handwerkliche fehler
dazu ein markenimage problem aber zum
thema große koalition
die strategie der spd konnte ja nicht
sagen eine große koalition einzugehen
und schlechte politik zu machen und
quasi täglich oder wöchentlich das auch
auszustrahlen als ob man fast genötigt
wäre zu regieren
das war ein mühsamer im
entscheidungsprozess aber wenn ich dann
in so eine koalition reingeht dann sind
die wählerinnen und wähler natürlich
haben das recht dass diese parteien über
einen vielleicht auch begrenzten
zeitraum als eine standard
legislaturperiode das beste tun um im
land gut zu regieren
ansonsten leidet die glaubwürdigkeit und
glaubwürdigkeit zu verspielen ist
einfacher als sie danach wieder zurück
zu üben
das problem ist also in die runde
geworfen jetzt an dem punkt da spielt ja
nicht nur die spd eine rolle also als
zurück die cdu wird ein problem haben
nach dem 29
im augenblick auch nur unter verdecke
gehalten wird und aus meiner sicht
könnte ein ereignis passieren dass man
eigentlich im parlament sozusagen den
stabwechsel in der union vorzieht dass
die ära merkel schneller beendet ist als
viele glauben weil man könnte aus der
mitte des parlaments in dem man jamaica
reaktiviert könnte einen neuen kanzler
oder eine neue kanzlerin wellen und der
spd käme es zu passt dann wurde man
nämlich neuwahlen vermeiden und vor
denen hat sowohl die union als auch die
spd natürlich schiss weil im augenblick
die gefahr besteht immer noch dass die
afg protestwähler aufsaugt in einem
ausmaß so dass die sozusagen die
regierungskonstellation eine
schwieriger wird magnete als gewagte
these erscheinen aber nach dem 29 werden
hier die puppen tanzen habe ich mir
sicher diese spekulation ja die wir hier
als stark politisch interessierte
täglich vornehmen der durchschnittliche
wähler wählerin selbst wenn er politisch
interessiert ist möchte eigentlich mehr
sagt politische orientierung möchte
seriosität in der auseinandersetzung
zwischen parteien die unumgänglich auch
mal in konflikte geraten und möchte
drittens vor allem nicht den eindruck
dass es ständig nur um persönliche
eitelkeiten und machtpolitische
spielchen geht das nährt letztendlich
genau den protest richtung an die
systemparteien und da haben denke ich
union und spd ordentliche hausaufgaben
spätestens nach der hessen-wahl sollten
sie die angehen weil ansonsten der
rückhalt in der bevölkerung nicht zu
nehmen für eine gerade dieser streit den
ist jetzt im sommer gab auch um diese
causa maßen da hat ja nun spd frau
nahles auch alles falsch eingeschätzt
und musste dann zurückrudern also da hat
sie doch eigentlich sehr schwach sehr
geht vom urlaub ist ja und wo man
gesehen hat da ist die spd eigentlich
gar nicht gut aufgestellt und kommt gar
nicht also als starke person da in der
großen koalition vor ja das hat glaube
ich viel in der spd auch überrascht weil
eigentlich heißt es ja bei andrea nahles
dass sie die partei in der sie schon so
lange ist in der sie schon auch so lange
wer ist wirklich gut kennt ich glaube da
hat sie sich einfach völlig verschätzt
auch da das war schon so einen punkt
holen der spd wirklich schockstarre
geherrscht hat wo man das nicht glauben
konnte die auch führungsspitze die
restliche führungsspitze waren glaube
ich sehr froh dass andrea nahles
irgendwann was ja auch selten ist in der
politik was vielleicht auch eher eine
frau macht als ein mann gesagt hat wir
haben da einen fehler gemacht wir müssen
das noch mal neu überlegen was wir da
machen aber das hat glaube ich vielen ja
viele zum nachdenken gebracht um zu
fragen was wie stark ist mit andrea
nahles unsere vorsitzende auch in dieser
doppelfunktion die er sicherlich auch
schwierig ist von der ihr auch manche
abgeraten haben also da hat die spd
glaube ich schon angefangen zu überlegen
mensch wie stehen wir hier da und
vielleicht noch eine frage was die sache
angeht wie geht man auch mit der union
um da moda herrscht in der spd ja keine
einigkeit ist ja auch so ein punkt dass
manche sagen wir müssen ganz geräuschlos
regieren
nichts machen was nach streit aussieht
und andere sagen nein wie sollen wir
denn in dieser regierung profil gewinnen
wenn wir nicht ab und zu auch mal sagen
schön dass wir das jetzt gemacht haben
mit der union aber eigentlich sollten
wir uns noch ganz andere dinge wünschen
wenn wir könnten wie wir wollten aber
wie sehr liegt es denn dann wirklich an
ihr an der frau an der spitze also
erfasst was würden sie sagen ist das
wenn andrea nahles anders auftreten
würde dann hätte spd einfach ganz andere
oder viel weniger probleme ist wie dann
doch diejenige an der sich auch ja nur
viele reiben gab die auseinandersetzung
mit kevin kühnert über die die sache
dass man eben nicht in die große
koalition geben dann ist das hängt das
der spd so nach dass es dann doch
letztendlich an ihr liegt der ich glaube
ihre werte sind nicht wirklich gut
das sehen wir ja auch in umfragen so
ziehen sie ist nicht die beliebteste
politikerin innerhalb der spd
da sind andere weit weit vor ihr ich
glaube in die partei hinein hat sie
schon durchaus positive impulse gesetz
an einigen stellen was man so hört
laufen sitzungen auch angenehmer als
früher
aber trotzdem ich meinen wenn wir
nochmal zurückdenken als martin schulz
inthronisiert wurde was das damals
ausgelöst hat in der spd und auch in der
bevölkerung insgesamt vergessen ist
irgend so ein bisschen aber das ist noch
keine zwei jahre her da schoss die spd
in umfragen an der union vorbei nach
oben hat in der politischen stimmung bei
der forschungsgruppe wahlen über 40%
plötzlich gelesen nicht in der
projektion aber in der stimmung über 40
prozent gelegen das war so ein moment wo
man glaube ich gedacht hat ja hier ist
plötzlich nochmal eine neue person die
es glaubwürdig die canvas auslösen es
war nicht nachhaltig aber es hat man
sich mal auf dem abstellgleis alles ist
ja denken sie ihren das ist sozusagen
wenige wochen nach der bundestagswahl
passierte sind niedersachsen als stephan
weil bestätigt worden
denken sie an malu dreyer rheinland
pfalz die grandiose aufgeholt hat also
da und man kann jetzt nicht so ein
abgesang auf die spd unisono hier singen
sondern man muss schon anerkennen dass
dort wo glaubwürdige pakete aus
programmen person vorhanden sind dass da
schon noch was geht aber daran hapert es
im moment einfach das gelingt der spd
nicht sozusagen so eine verbindung aus
personen programm zu präsentieren
die irgendwie dann noch dazu auch nach
vorne schauen was interessantes
perspektivisch anbietet das geringe
unterschlagen natürlich ein
thema das eine strukturelle eine
tektonische verschiebung auslöst in den
letzten also wir hatten mit dem
flüchtlingsthema ein eruptive
wiederaufstehung da fdp die ja in der
euro-krise gegründet wurde und damals
sozusagen über die fünf prozent kam und
wenn man sieht dass sozusagen von der
linken von der spd von der union wähler
in den protest gehen weil sie sich hier
unverstanden fühlen an einem thema
kulturelle überfremdung kriminalität
massenmigration missbrauch des
asylrechts in teilen
thematisiert wird an dem rubicon da
scheiden sich gewaltig die geister und
da spielen das bild zumindest in meiner
wahrnehmung eine viel größere rolle bei
den tektonischen verschiebungen am
kurzen ende als zb endlich mal soziale
frage insgesamt eine frage und also ich
bring den einwand deshalb weil ich auch
nicht das totenglöckchen für die spd
leute ganz bestimmt nicht also da muss
man auch mal historisch sich klar machen
ihr habt mir heute mittag war wusste in
die sendung zu gehen die otto wels rede
vom 23 märz 33 hier im reich im
hinterkopf aber war es nicht im
reichstag der war ausgebrannt angehört
und wänden fraktionsvorsitzende wo die
kpd abgeordnete verhaftet waren 26
sozialdemokraten schon nicht mehr
teilnehmen konnten wenn 94
sozialdemokraten bei gefahr für leib und
leben mit nein zum ermächtigungsgesetz
stimmen dann hat seine partei für mich
sozusagen einen sozusagen moralischen
resonanzraum den ich nicht kleinreden
will da können die sich jetzt nichts vom
kauf neuer das sag ich mal
und es muss man auch als können die sich
da könnten sie sich davon was kaufen
wenn sie anders damit vielleicht umgehen
würden ist das ein punkt wo man sagen
könnte
die spd könnte eigentlich ihre ihre
geschichte darauf wo sie stehe immer
sagen sie ist so stolz die stolze partei
müsste das eigentlich anders
präsentieren oder ist es wirklich vorbei
sie also das würde nicht schaden aber
wahrscheinlich auch wenig nutzen
wählerinnen und wähler belohnen selten
hat ein für errungenschaften oder
verhalten das 80 90 jahre ist sondern
sie wünschen sich vor allem aussagen für
die zukunft orientierung bei den
wichtigen themen
ich würde auch nur einen schwenker
machen auf die wahlzeit 2015 hat die spd
bei elf landtagswahlen neunmal
prozentpunkte verloren sie hat zweimal
hinzugewonnenen rheinland pfalz war das
minimal nicht nur einen prozentpunkt und
die einzige ausreißer war in dieser
entwicklung war tatsächlich zwei wochen
nach der bundestagswahl mit stephan weil
und der speziell niedersachsen also der
trend ist eindeutig nach unten und das
spielen ganz unterschiedliche faktoren
sind personelle faktoren personen können
in der regel keine strukturellen krisen
beseitigen aber spielen natürlich auch
diese personellen auseinandersetzung in
der spd ein stück weit um die richtige
kurssetzung mit hinein und die die
hauptgeschichte ist ja dass wir derzeit
einen virus der unzufriedenheit mit der
regierungsarbeit haben und es trifft
beide klassischen volksparteien die spd
ist halt immer mit noch ein stück weit
verlässlicheren socken arbeit wir müssen
feststellen dass im moment keiner der
handelnden akteure zufriedenheitswerte
von 50 prozent plus aufweisen die ganze
bundesregierung wird nur von dem viertel
der menschen in deutschland gut bewertet
das sind natürlich schon werte die
kommen immer mal wieder vor
aber das zeigt natürlich schon dass wir
in einer politischen stimmungslage sind
wo es ganz normales dass die wahren
glocken geläutet werden wenn auch nicht
die totenglöckchen das schlimmste für
eine datei ist ja wenn der politische
gegner mit leitheußer damit am
samstagabend ja gesagt hat in thun die
vielen wahlkämpfe der spd in bayern die
so tapfer gekämpft haben und dann auch
cdu politiker sagen also das wünschen
sie ihrem ärgsten gegner in dieser zeit
schon wie angeschlagen die spd ist ja
ein bisschen dass niedersachsen phänomen
auch waren die klatsche bei der
bundestagswahl und dann glaube ich schon
so ein moment um ganz so schlecht hat
die spd einig doch nicht verdient und
das hat stephan weil schon auch zu
nutzen
wir müssen jetzt umso mehr kämpfen das
könnte man für hessen auch vermuten
zumal mit schäfer-gümbel oder der
konstellation insgesamt ich meine die
herausforderung für die spd in bayern
war einfach dass sie noch nicht mal die
natürliche herausforderung mehr war für
die csu und das ist den hessen schon
anders
sie ist schon die klare herausforderung
für diese schwarz grüne regierung und
das spielt er und ich glaube auch den
spitzenkandidaten da er in die hände
weil sie natürlich auftrag ich meine wir
hatten heute das tv duell in bayern
waren natascha kohnen noch nicht mal da
zugegen und das ist einfach dass die spd
dort völlig abstrakt sie haben eben du
wirst glaubwürdige gesamtkonzept schon
was wichtig ist ist tausendmal ist dass
jemand in hessen from iwo sagen der ist
gleichauf mit dem ministerpräsident und
da gibt es wirklich
also da die sind also als gegner auf
augenhöhe
also ich glaube die chancen dass er
ministerpräsident wird sind nicht so
groß auch wenn die in den letzten
umfragen spd und cdu relativ nah
beieinander lagen vor allem wenn man
sich mal die rohdaten anguckt aber ich
glaube dass die spd schon einiges
richtig gemacht hat in hessen was ihren
bayern auch falsch gemacht hat
zum beispiel dass sie mit großen vorlauf
zur wahl sehr klar gesagt hat was sind
unsere themen also dieses themen hopping
was wir im bundestagswahlkampf gesehen
haben das macht schäfer gümbel nicht
mehr ganz klar gesagt 123 wohnen
mobilität bildung das sind meine themen
daran hält er sich daran arbeitet er
sich ab das heißt es wird hoffentlich
auch irgendwann im kopf der wähler
angekommen sein ich hör teilweise aus
der spd wenn der arbeitsminister
unterwegs ist dann trifft er auf leute
die auch spd sympathisanten sind die
sagen dann könnt ihr nicht mal was
machen irgendwie rückkehrrecht teilzeit
vollzeit sondern sagt er hier übrigens
gesetzentwurf dann sagen die karte
niemals machen sozialer arbeitsmarkt und
da sagt er jedoch
also ich glaube das ist schon ganz
wichtig das ist die spd wirklich mal
wieder schafft einfach die wichtigen
punkte für sich klar zu haben da auch
eine klare linie zu haben denn das am
see grad eben gesagt das ist ja in
vielen punkten und nicht der fall was
ist beim thema klima andrea nahles wird
sich manchmal so an die afg klimawandel
leuten da sind genauso schlimm wie die
die voll auf klimaschutz setzen und so
weiter also da muss die spd bei so
vielen themen das mal klar kriegen und
ich glaube das ist in hessen gut
gelaufen
ob das nun auch schäfer-gümbel als
ministerpräsident rausläuft sehe ich
noch nicht unbedingt zumindest nicht als
stärkste partei aber wer weiß was dann
noch an ampel und so weiter geht wenn es
für schwarz grün nicht reicht da ist
einiges denkbar so eine machtoption hat
die spd in hessen auf jeden fall die
hatte sie in bayern 0
bringen sie aber gemeinsam vorhandene
einfach wäre
na gut die verhältnisse sind anders als
in bayern es ist natürlich klar das
schicksal der deutschen sozialdemokratie
würde ich gerne landtagswahl in bayern
entschieden genauso wenig wie in sachsen
sachsen anhalt oder thüringen hessen ist
das schon relevanter weil es über viele
jahrzehnte spd regiert war das land ist
auch so ein bisschen gespalten regional
süden da ist stärker schwarz dominiert
der der norden er eher rot und klar ist
der abstand zwischen der cdu und der spd
nach den letzten vorwahl erhebung viel
geringer und es findet sogar noch ein tv
duell mit vertretern der beiden
klassischen volksparteien stadt die
entscheidende frage wird sein ob dieser
wahlkampf den thorsten schäfer gümpel
natürlich jetzt genauso übrigens wie
volker bouffier oder dem schlagwort
führt hessen ist nicht bayern und hessen
ist nicht bunt ob das zündet also
inwieweit können dann spitzenkandidaten
in den landtagswahlkämpfen sich von
sagen wir mal gegenwind vom bund her
entkoppeln das ist dann immer die frage
da ist hoffen und bangen bis zum schluss
ja irgendwie verrückt dass man sich
dagegen absetzen muss und dass man eben
nicht durch den bundes spd gestützt wird
ich glaube dass es nicht wirklich
verrücktes sondern die konsequenz des
föderalistischen systems das quasi dazu
führt dass wir irgendwo immer gerade
wahlkampf haben überspitzt ausgedrückt
war natürlich auch längere phasen wohl
nicht gewählt wird aber das ist eben der
unterschied zur central staatlichen
demokratien wie in großbritannien
und das führt dazu dass immer die frage
ist ja wie wirken bundes und
landespolitische trends bei einzelnen
wahlen aufeinander
klar ist dass thorsten schäfer gümbel
als person solidität seriosität versucht
zu verkörpern mit landespolitischen
themen versucht zu punkten im endeffekt
wird sich zeigen ob das erfolgreich ist
oder nicht das werden wir aber erst in
elf tagen ließen aber wichtig ist den
die fragen aber er hat sich bestimmte
themen gekümmert aber das hat man auch
im duell gesehen gerade wohnen war ein
ganz wichtiges thema aber das ist ja
nicht das große thema der
sozialdemokratie wo man sagt das ist
unverwechselbar sozial demokratisch
verfasst was würden sie sagen ist
sozusagen das thema wo man sagt das kann
ein
die spd naja es ist erst mal der wert
soziale gerechtigkeit und die themen die
sie ja auch genannt haben lassen sich
damit glaube ich schon sehr sehr gut
verbinden
und natürlich haben sie recht dass das
migrationsthemen die vergangenen jahre
geprägt hat aber das ist eins für die
spd einfach sehr sehr gefährlich ist
weil das nicht dasjenige oder das ist
nicht die dimension über ganz offen die
funktionärsebene der partei wieder in
see um november ebene über die die spd
definiert ist sondern das ist eine
sozioökonomische da geht es um
ungleichheit ungerechtigkeit und diese
kulturelle identitäten fragen die jeden
dazu einfach quer und das tut der union
weil sie damit nicht gut umgehen kann
das tut der spd weil sie damit nicht gut
umgehen kann da hat sie befürworter wie
gegner gehen rein und das afg und grüne
gerade gut dastehen da das liegt eben
auch daran dass die beiden parteien wenn
es um fragen von offenheit
geschlossenheit tradition moderne
gegebenheiten als darüber sind sie
relativ klar definiert deswegen spielt
ihre themen genau deswegen spielt
solange wir über dieses thema reden das
spielt diesen beiden parteien in die
hände
und da hat die spd natürlich auch
definitionsmacht worüber sie redet und
worüber sie nicht redet insofern kann
man ihr schon raten dass sie eigentlich
auch wenn sie über die migrationsfrage
redet dass er durch eine brille soziale
gerechtigkeit tun sollte die ard macht
genau umgekehrt die guckt auf alle
themen durch die flüchtlings brille
drauf und die spd könnte es anders
machen aber das tut sie malt eads hatte
machte aber einen riesenfehler schlagen
wir mal den bogen größer wenn ich an die
aktuelle regierungspolitik denke also
ich finde wirtschaftspolitisch ist es
eine ziemliche katastrophe war es mir
gerade machen dann bereich sozialstaat
da stellt sich in sozialdemokratische
finanzminister und stellvertretender
parteivorsitzender hin und sagt wir
müssen sozusagen den deutschen trend
bekämpfen ist gleich afd bekämpfen und
machen dann die schleusen auf kurz
vorher in den demographischen sozusagen
absturz bringen was jetzt alters
versorgungssysteme betrifft
krankenversicherung pflegeversicherung
und und schreiben praktisch dein
rentenniveaus fest in der hoffnung dass
man auf die art und weise verhindert als
nämlich gerade kleine leute sagen für
die fremden tue da alles und für die
inländer toter nichts das ist ja
sozusagen die der die botschaft die
dahinter steckt dass man aber
gleichzeitig so viel falsche erwartungen
weckt die wir
objektiven gründen nicht erfüllen können
wenn wir jetzt die babyboomer in
ruhestand schicken das verstehe ich
nicht und insofern wenn dann noch
sozusagen die die paradoxe intervention
aus spd parteifunktionärs kreisen kommt
dass man sozusagen er tendenziell offene
grenzen will und freundlich und
multikulturell sein will dann versteht
natürlich fußvolk diesen zwiespalt erst
recht nicht also da ist weil sie auf
bayern schauen nico sigel hat gesagt die
abwanderung zum allergrössten drei
gegenden richtung der grünen also diese
these dass die es neben massenweisen
herr weitaus mehr also der austausch ist
sehr praktisch eins zu eins die grünen
haben zehn prozent gesunken sind ist
nicht seit kurzem 1000 komplexe also der
strom ist mit den fäusten strom link
zwischenrang
es ist nicht so fern darf sich die spd
diese erzählungen nicht zu eigen machen
dass die afg so wenn sie die das
versucht wenn sie dieses thema bedient
das wird sie zerreißen das ist nicht das
thema muss sie definiert aber was mit
sofort welches thema muss sie bedienen
und wo kann sie sagen wenn sie jetzt in
die zukunft schauen
sie versucht ja seit januar heißt immer
wir müssen uns erneuern erneuern und das
funktioniert ja nicht also man weiß ja
nicht mehr genau wofür sie steht dran
naja ich bin wirklich mal gespannt was
bei diesem großen debatten camp damit er
noch einmal raus kommt die spd hält sich
im moment noch ein bisschen zurück die
spitzenleute die da irgendwie hinter den
kulissen in ihren arbeitsgruppen
arbeiten weil sie eben sagen wir wollen
jetzt mal die basis hören mitte november
ob sich dann da wirklich was tut mein
eindruck ist ja wirklich das in viel zu
vielen fragen einfach nicht geklärt ist
wo will die spd hin was will sie beim
thema klima was es genau mit der agenda
und so weiter das wird mitte november
auch nicht geklärt werden
debatten käme aber das müsste endlich
mal geklärt werden weil die spd auch
glaube ich langsam merkt diesen zeitplan
den sie sich gesetzt hat ende 2009
zehnmal klare aussagen zu haben das ist
eigentlich zu lang das muss john dalli
sogar weil er bei der frage wollen wir
mitregieren oder nicht dieser großen
koalition schon so eine zerreißprobe
erlebt und das kann sie doch nicht bei
jedem thema dann machen das sind dann
merkt man doch dass das dass man da dann
muss doch irgendwann jemand auch in der
spd sagen ja da wollen wir hin
das müsste tatsächlich mal jemand sagen
aber das ist natürlich schwierig weil
die spd nun mal auch nicht die cdu ist
ich meine haben
wiedergesehen die hatte einen brinkhaus
beben und irgendwie drei tage später war
eigentlich schon alles fast wieder
business as usual so funktioniert die
spd nicht
ja das würde sich die spd vielleicht
auch manchmal wer schon da ist das
glaube ich schwieriger aber tatsächlich
die müssen jetzt irgendwann mal wirklich
zu potte kommen und einfach ein paar
dinge klar ziehen
also ich glaube jetzt nicht dass die spd
im moment die partei ist die hat immer
intern mit sich gerungen und war auch
immer ganz gut beraten bestimmte
diskussionen anders aus zu tragen als
die union weil sie viel stärker eine
programmpartei war es die union
ich wollte war auf den das bild von
thorsten faas zurück um mit der brille
durch die soziale gerechtigkeit was
durchaus sinn macht was aber gar nicht
geht ist zu sagen auf diese kulturelle
kulturellen konflikt diene der äußere
ich mich lieber nicht das überlasse ich
so ein bisschen auch der diskussion
zwischen fdp und union weil es zeigt
sich eben das ist parteien gibt
sozialdemokratisch in europa die durch
die brille der sozialen gerechtigkeit
vor allem politik gestalten wollen aber
bei der migrationspolitik eine
positionierung eingenommen haben die
deutlich rechts ist von der deutschen
sozialdemokratie ein schwedisches
sozialdemokratie wir werden mit unserem
schwesterinstitut in großbritannien in
der canter gruppe in dem nächsten
umfrage veröffentlichen da zeigt sich
dass nur labour bei mitte 30 prozent
ungefähr steht das heißt das
totenglöckchen soll ja noch nicht
geläutet werden aber die spd muss sich
in beiden zentralen konfliktlinien
positionieren das eine ist die
klassische sozialstaatliche oder
sozioökonomische andere ist die
politisch kulturelle weil sie sonst
zunehmend an rückhalt verliert und weil
wir auch eines nicht vergessen dürfen
die die vorstellung einer einer
libertären elite die der sie progressiv
in der in der migrationspolitik äußert
ja die trinkt ja nicht einmal mehr unter
die jung- und erstwählern so durch und
mit ein das heißt eine deutliche studio
lokalisierte über migrationsfragen
diskutiert als es eben tatsächlich auf
der funktionärsebene und innerhalb der
politischen elite gemacht wird
das ist im endeffekt nährboden für die
afg wenn sich eine partei wie opitz
union oder spd bei diesem wirklich
zentralen thema letztendlich nicht der
auseinandersetzung bedient das gehört
dazu
da kann man nicht wirklich wegtauchen
das hat sich ein bayern eines gezeigt
das muss man schon sagen der csu ist
vieles müssen wirklich sehr weit ist es
historisch schlechtes wahlergebnis aber
die afg lag jetzt in bayern bei der
landtagswahl was die gesamtstimmen
angeht die anteile unterhalb des
zweitstimme ergebnisses bei der
bundestagswahl
wenn wir aber über soziale gerechtigkeit
reden dann ist einmal die frage ist denn
dann die linke nicht sozusagen die
partei die das schon längst auf ihre
fahnen geschrieben hat und da kann die
spd dann auch nicht mehr gewinnen weil
wir das wirklich will der wählt dann die
linke klar ich meine das ist das was
nico sigel eben mit dem historisch fast
schon verweis auf die agenda 2010
natürlich in erinnerung gerufen hat
diese linke ist entstanden im kontext
der agenda 2010 und das tut der spd bis
heute weh die große gefahr für die union
jetzt mit blick auf die ard dass da
plötzlich auch eben von der anderen
seite konkurrenz aufkommen aber nicht
sagen ob wir müssen jetzt mal den streit
auf oder den hass auf wenders von thema
beiseite lassen müssen einfach mal sagen
wir müssen wirklich mit denen zusammen
aber in wenn sie so jetzt wird er jetzt
kann ich sagen die grünen sind keine
linke partei mehr aber wenn sie auf
bayern mal schauen und sagen und
addieren einfach mal linke grüne und spd
dann hat sich kaum muss verschoben
zwischen den letzten zwei land 1
0-siegen ungefähr weitere 36 bern denn
so was ähnliches sehen sie auch auf
bundesebene also sie sehen ja vor allem
auch ganz starke verschiebungen
innerhalb von bestimmten lagern so das
was sie sagen durchaus richtig ist dass
man sagen wir okay das ist ein auftrag
an linke parteien einfach
konstellationen zu finden in denen diese
linken parteien sollten zusammenarbeiten
können aber das gelingt hat einfach noch
nicht auf bundesebene nicht und in
vielen man dann sind wir wieder wachsen
wird
auch da ist es ein fragezeichen aber
natürlich machtperspektive es eben schon
gefallen wenn die
das ist eben der alte volkspartei
charakter der spd über den wir sozusagen
heute noch nicht gesprochen haben aber
natürlich gehört auch zur dna der spd
dass sie eigentlich sozusagen
alternierend mit der union regiert und
das ist gerade in gefahr wir haben sie
in bayern gesehen wenn es in baden
württemberg
deswegen ist vielleicht also ist es
einfach sehr sehr schwierig und auch
wirklich eine situation die
außergewöhnlich und vielleicht nicht
existenzgefährdend ist aber zumindest
für den für den status der spd wirklich
gefährlich kann man könnte man auch
sagen die spd als partei die vor allen
dingen für verarbeiter gekämpft hat die
und so eine lange geschichte hat hat
sozusagen ja ihre mission erfüllt und
das thema große ja der der rechte für
arbeiter ist irgendwie erfüllt und jetzt
ist sie irgendwann überflüssig
er macht das glaube ich eigentlich nicht
wenn ich meine ich glaube es ist falsch
ist wenn man das gefühl hat bei andrea
nahles teilweise dass sie nur noch für
die wie viele sind 20.000 bergbau kumpel
in deutschland kämpft dann ist das
natürlich ein bisschen sehr eng weil die
werden die spd nicht retten aber wenn
wir mal auf die letzten jahre schwarz
rote regierung zurück gucken also ich
würde jetzt nicht sagen dass die spd da
überflüssig gewesen wäre also wenn wir
an mindestlohn an frauenquote und an
andere dinge eher für alle das wäre er
nicht gekommen wenn die spd nicht mit
regiert hätte also da jetzt sozusagen
die brauchen wir eigentlich nicht mehr
mission erfüllt sehe ich so nicht aber
es ist natürlich schwierig vor allem
auch wenn die spd sich überlegen muss
wohl die cdu in irgend einer zeit nach
angela merkel wohl stehen wird das kann
man natürlich sehr strategisch nennen so
sagen na okay wenn die cdu wieder weiter
nach rechts rückt wieder mehr platz für
uns in der mitte wollen wir da hin oder
wollen wir doch er dezidiert linker
werden aber so kann man das natürlich
betrachten und von daher ist es
natürlich auch nicht leicht für die spd
also entweder setzen sie sich zusammen
und sagt ganz klar da wollen wir
tatsächlich hin oder sie guckt sehr viel
strategischer wo wird vielleicht wieder
raum für uns frei und sollten wir den
nutzen und genau das ist das problem
also ich diskutiere sie ja nicht gerne
nur aus blickwinkel der spd die union
hat durch das gleiche strategische
dilemma mittlerweile ja genau weil die
hat die scheunentore aufgemacht für eine
partei rechts von ihr strauss hatte
doch damals diesen spruch drauf rechts
von uns darf keine demokratische partei
großwagen das hat sie versäumt das uns
war die weichenstellung viel 215
ich habe immer hart ran
drei jahren im frühjahr war die afg im
bundestrend fast unter fünf prozent als
sich von lucke getrennt hatten und dann
kam das xoom oder august
die öffnung der grenzen im september und
ab dem zeitpunkt leider ist wie ein
katalysator und aber die spd aber die
probleme der spd sind ja schon viel
länger da der spd sind natürlich länger
da also jetzt war ich ja bitte spd
mitglied bis 79 als junger mann und
bildern 87 zu den grünen sei es für den
bundestag ich habe die zeit erlebt wo
praktisch die grünen der gottseibeiuns
der anderen parteien waren und die
grünen die altparteien attackiert hatten
aber die grünen waren natürlich in das
aus der sicht der sozialdemokraten
fleisch vom fleische der spd
und das war am anfang so und das war der
erste strategische fehler die spd hatte
einen erhard eppler in baden württemberg
übrigens die union in den 70er jahren
einen abgeordneten namens herbert gruhl
die die öko frage versucht haben zu
pushen und das war die erste abspaltung
und dann kamen die wiedervereinigung die
pds dann kann die agenda und da hat
schröder den fehler gemacht aber dass
das mehr unterscheiden muss zwischen
großen strukturellen linien ja und da
ist eben deutschland mittlerweile eine
ganz klassische kontinentaleuropäische
demokratie in der es links von der
sozialdemokratie eine partei gibt die
die linke heißt es gibt eine ökologische
partei und es gibt rechts von der cdu
eine partei wie die afd
aber das hätte man es ist eine
normalisierung des deutschen
parteiensystems die auch den
strukturellen und sozialen wandel in
deutschland gut erklärt natürlich können
einzelne ereignisse solche solche
architektonische verschiebung dann
befördern aber sie sind meistens nur
anlässe symptome wie bei iceberg man
zieht die spitze
ja darunter ist der eisberg schon längst
geschmolzen und die union ist wenn ich
den satz noch sagen darf natürlich jetzt
auch endlich in der sandwich position
wie die spd
aber auch das ist ein ganz normales
stück europäisches parteiensystem im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert weil eben
die großen christdemokratischen und
sozialdemokratischen parteien nicht mehr
diese milieus hinter sich vereinen und
trotzdem werden wir auch in zukunft
keine klare linie haben bei allen fragen
denn das macht eben große parteien aus
der wird intern durchaus gestritten da
gibt es unterschiedliche flügel das
entscheidende ist nur dass sich in
entscheidenden situationen
vorwarnen und wenn ich in der regierung
beteiligt bin dann über einen
überschaubaren zeitraum relativ
geschlossen nach außen agieren und der
blick auf die union nach angela merkel
ist halt auch schüler sozusagen
taktische orientierung das wird der spd
nicht wirklich weiterhelfen das kann man
nicht sagen jetzt schauen wir noch mal
was passiert jetzt passieren in hessen
wenn die spd auch ein schlechtes
ergebnis bekommt und nicht mitregiert
ist dann die richtige konsequenz zu
sagen okay wir müssen uns jetzt doch auf
eine andere art erneuern wir müssen raus
aus dieser großen koalition wäre das
richtig ich glaube dass das durchaus
richtig sein könnte ich glaube aber
nicht aus meiner einschätzung dass es so
schnell kommen wird weil wie gesagt
darüber dieses weiterwurschteln wie
immer und dann handelt man weiter marl
und und die jemand weder jüdische
kleinen kühnert versucht ja sozusagen
schon den den anlass zu schaffen dass
man aussteigen könnte der hat
vorgeschlagen lassen uns doch nach der
hessen wahl so einen forderungskatalog
machen und wenn der nicht bis zum
jahresende abgearbeitet ist dann müssen
wir sagen wir müssen da jetzt raus also
ich glaube so direkt ausstieg da denken
mittlerweile auch die linken in der spd
nicht darüber nach weil sie einfach
wissen das ist vermutlich nicht
vermittelbar wäre
andere leute diese klausel im
koalitionsvertrag dass man nach zwei
jahren gucken genau das ist dann schon
ein bisschen weithin keine ahnung
vielleicht müsste man es zusammen mit
der europawahl machen ich meine was man
ja auch mal sagen muss die spd hat kein
geld für wahlkampf da schauen glaube ich
zumindest ein paar bei den genossen auch
drauf und sagen wir haben weder einen
kandidaten für die neuwahl wir haben
weder geld für den wahlkampf
also ran aus logistischen gründen ist
glaube ich bei vielen die lust nicht so
ausgeprägt jetzt irgendwie alles hin
zwischen alpha welt was würden sie denn
sagen wir das was könnte was könnte das
für ein vorteil bringen wenn man jetzt
sagen würde okay wir lassen wir machen
jetzt wirklich mal einen harten schnitt
es gibt so viel unmut und ist jedes mal
gibt's probleme wir machen jetzt in
hanstedt wir gehen aus der gruppe und
dann erneuern wir uns in der opposition
also erstmal ist glaube ich nicht klar
definiert auch was diese erneuerung sein
soll dann geht es um inhalte da geht es
auch mal ganz stark auch um die
organisation spd die zur debatte steht
und insofern ist dieser begriff
glaublich fluch und segen zugleich
nochmal ich habe die frage ist
tatsächlich eine die sich um
glaubwürdigkeit dreht und das scheint
mir schon verknüpft mit dieser großen
koalition und die drogen nach bayern
fand ich schon relativ explizit
formuliert dass wenn es in dieser art
und weise in der großen koalition
weitergehen sollte diesem stil dass man
sich einfach misstraut in der koalition
dass man eben nicht zur berühmt
berüchtigen sacharbeit zurückkehren kann
dann macht es keinen sinn für die spd
und das kann man auch so sehen weil
diese strategische überlegungen dann
tatsächlich nicht greift sich einfach
durch solide arbeit auch das hören wir
ja schon länger ich meine es war ja auch
eigentlich das narrativ für die letzte
große koalition wir haben gute arbeit
gemacht hat was gebracht nein ein
historisch schlechtes wahlergebnis
insofern werden die kritiker in der spd
natürlich sagen guck mal das ist genau
das was wir gesagt haben das wiederholt
sich all das was in der letzten
legislaturperiode passiert ist und das
ist glaube ich der große unterschied zur
union vor allem zur cdu dass das
mitglied seien in der großen koalition
dort eigentlich nicht wirklich in frage
gestellt wird aber in der spd natürlich
einfach ein ganz starkes ich schön ist
was umstritten ist war es eine gute
entscheidung ja oder nein
und das bleibt einfach und diese
wahlergebnisse sind wasser auf die
mühlen der kritiker hat das ist doch
nicht die spd will nicht wirklich
regierenden kamen die seele der partei
ist eigentlich immer ein stück weit auch
opposition und die cdu hat im kreis ist
eine grundsätzlich sagen nein ich würde
das grundsätzlich sagen sogar aus meiner
aus meiner erfahrung und also ich kenne
ja genügend genossinnen und genossen aus
meiner zeit die absolut sagen alt
geworden sind und das ist ein thema in
der union ist ein viel
selbstverständlicher umgang mit macht
und was sie übrigens schon regieren die
sehnsucht nach runderneuerung opposition
ist so lang wie die sozialdemokratische
regierungsbeteiligung aber sie hat halt
immer auch auf länder eben die
mitregiert und deshalb war es auch nie
wirklich faktischen option weil sie auch
jetzt noch sieben ministerpräsidenten
oder eben regierende bürgermeister
stellt aber ein rundes erneuerung ist
das leben und muss ich ja sagen
funktioniert ja also ich meine
tatsächlich internet wenn man gar nicht
reden da fragt wie viele von ihnen
sozusagen eine sozialdemokratische
affinität wir haben aber im endeffekt
glauben sie mir das ist ein unterschied
das cdu-mitglied wird im zweifelsfall
immer sagen und viele cdu-wähler
übrigens auch die fdp-wähler tomate die
jetzt problem mit dem ausstieg aus
jamaika
wenn man die chance hat zu regieren dann
regiert man beim in der regierung zu
mehr machen opposition ist mist war
müntefering richtige ausspruch aber
leider ist der nicht inhaliert sozusagen
vom funktioniert ich glaube man muss
nicht meiner spd affinität haben um zu
sagen dass es aber auch in dieser partei
im kern an leuten gibt die gerne
regieren wollen und die fragen als
fragen sind ja aber durch die natürlich
auch durchaus richtig sagen wenn wir
nicht mitregieren können wir bestimmte
dinge auch nicht durchsetzen dass bei
der cdu sicherlich weniger ausgeprägt
ist dieses lasst uns lieber opposition
machen aber ich meine auch in hessen
haben es gesehen so toll hat sich die
spd in 20 jahren fast 20 jahren
opposition dort auch nicht erneuert dass
sie jetzt sozusagen den durchmarsch
machen würde und das klar wäre dass sie
den nächsten ministerpräsidenten stellt
also opposition ist auch kein garant für
klar erneuerung und ich lieber berger
gibt es gibt es jemanden der spd der
kanzler fähig ist im moment
naja wenn sie sich die zahlen der
forschungsgruppe bahn angucken olaf
scholz ist sicherlich sehr beliebt dass
ein ähnliches phänomen wie wir es bei
steinburg damals hatten wir auch sehr
beliebt war der dann aber am wahltag
doch nicht so geliefert hat aber
trotzdem ich meine nico sigel hat die
ministerpräsidentin ministerpräsident
angesprochen sind nicht so dass es keine
personen in der spd gibt die keine
führungserfahrung sagen also der
vizekanzler wäre in der jetzigen
situation sicherlich der kanzlerkandidat
wenn man jetzt einen benennen müsste
aber ob er das zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
gerne tun würde ist dann natürlich noch
mal leben würden sie denn da sehen was
ich empfinde da ist demoscope gar nicht
so wird auch die affinität zu spd in
umfragen es war eine faktische
feststellung es gab immer in der spd
flügel der sehnsucht nach opposition an
das war immer mehr der linke flügel
der pragmatische flügel hat wie gerd
schröder gerne an den toren titel weil
auch dort natürlich klar die 18 ist wir
nicht regieren kann ich gestalten die
runderneuerung könnte ja nur
funktionieren wenn man nicht den boden
euro
das ist der kern des problems kanzler
der glaube dass olaf scholz in großer
teil der genossen nicht gerne als
kanzlerkandidaten sehen möchte
das sieht man auch an seinen
innerparteilichen wahlergebnissen das
kann auch für entsprechende leistungen
wie man sieht ich war mit manuela
schwesig im wahlkampf unterwegs die
kommt sehr positiv an bei den leuten
kann man darüber streiten ob man mir das
zutraut stephan weil den namen höre ich
öfter also es gibt leute mal sogar
vermutlich direkt auf stellen aber da
geht es wahrscheinlich auch aufgrund der
fall so das müssen wir noch klären und
wir sind erst mal alle gespannt wie
diese hessen wahl ausgeht und was danach
passiert hier in berlin ganz herzlichen
dank für die diskussion das war die
phoenix runde heute aber morgen schauen
wir auf den brics it denn da sagt man ja
gerade in brüssel ist auch spannend
genug ich hoffe sie sind wieder dabei
bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]